[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
de la grande interview installés de
façon exceptionnelle dans ce centre
culturel orthodoxe russe à l'ombre de
l'église orthodoxe que tous les
parisiens maintenant connaissent dans ce
quartier de l'alma à paris sur la rive
gauche
émission un peu particulière puisque
nous recevons nous sommes reçus par la
ministre de la culture de la fédération
de russie olga l'oubli mova merci la
société active accordé cet entretien
vous êtes à paris à l'occasion de
l'inauguration de l'exposition de la
collection
des frères morozov à la fondation
vuitton
inauguration qui a eu lieu en présence
d'emmanuel macron le président de la
république qui a saisi l'occasion
d'ailleurs de dire que cet événement
marquait la proximité forte entre la
france et la russie cette collection
madame la ministre est absolument unique
au monde et nous permet de découvrir des
trésors de la peinture du 19e siècle et
du début du 20e siècle peintures
européennes françaises russes aussi des
pièces de matisse de sead de renoir des
tableaux qu'on avait jamais vu nulle
part peut-être un peu à moscou et
peut-être à saint pétersbourg pouvez
vous nous raconter
l'histoire de cette collection d'où elle
vient cette collection
les frères morozov sont deux
collectionneurs unique qui ont vécu au
tournant des 19e et 20e siècles
ils sont décédés tous deux peu de temps
avant la révolution
de collectionneurs au flair et augmenter
stick
grâce à eux nous avons un héritage
extraordinaire
environ 400 toiles d'artistes russes et
deux cent cinquante toiles d'artistes
d'europe occidentale
non non
zapatero madame la ministre tous ces
tableaux rue de vie très chahuté depuis
la mort des frères
morozov comment s'est déroulée cette
histoire et comment est-ce que la russie
d'aujourd'hui a ressorti ses tableaux
dans l'actualité pour les présenter
en effet la collection morozov a élu son
domicile au musée de l'ermitage au musée
des beaux-arts pouchkine et à la galerie
tretiakov de moscou
il existe en russie une association de
musée on courait vite très
harmonieusement entre nous c'est donc
une pratique courante surtout pour de si
grands projets
on appelle ça des expositions de grande
envergure
quand les trois des plus grands musées
s'unissent pour présenter toute la
splendeur d'une collection à l'étranger
comme c'est le cas à paris en ce moment
les cas les bras
madame la ministre si j'ai bien compris
il ya eu une initiative très forte d'un
groupe financier et industriel français
le groupe lvmh avec son président
bernard arnault mais il ya eu aussi la
conjonction de deux ambitions de volonté
politique diplomatique moscou d'un côté
paris de l'autre comment ça s'est passé
concrètement parce que ça a mis du temps
plusieurs années un pour débloquer cette
affaire et hors tabac il s'agit de la
deuxième exposition en collaboration
avec la fondation louis vuitton
la première a été accueilli très
chaleureusement à paris en 2016 c'était
la collection schukin elle a attiré un
million trois cent mille visiteurs ce
qui était bien sûr très important à la
fois pour la fondation louis vuitton et
pour les organisateurs du côté russe le
ministère de la culture il était très
important pour nous de poursuivre ce
dialogue
cette exposition a été attendu depuis
non nous étions dérangé par la pandémie
mais nous avons parfaitement compris
qu'il fallait attendre jusqu'à ce que la
situation épidémiologique à paris
permettent aux visiteurs de renouveler
leur découverte de la russe il était
très important pour nous d'arriver à ce
moment car les trois des plus grands
musées russes attendait cette exposition
avec impatience et bien sûr son
annulation n'était absolument pas
envisageable une exposition des oeuvres
dia repin sera présentée un peu plus
tard au sein du petit palais et j'en
suis sûre qu'elle aura un grand succès
la galerie tretiakov et les
organisateurs de cette exposition ont
attendu pendant une année entière
l'amélioration de la situation
épidémiologique
ce moment où les gens pourront venir
voir les oeuvres dia repin alors même la
ministre la curiosité des français des
européens est très importante en
témoigne mais le succès des expositions
précédentes que vous venez de de
rappeler quelle est l'histoire que la
russie veut raconter au monde
en facilitant l'exportation de tels
trésors
tout d'abord nous voulions présenter des
peintures exceptionnelles
les toiles qui seront présentées lors de
cette exposition sont de véritables
chefs-d'oeuvre je pense que cette
exposition hormis les professionnels
intéressera le grand public aussi bien
que les visiteurs en tout genre on peut
visiter cette exposition en famille avec
des enfants ce sont des oeuvres d'art
vraiment exceptionnel mais en même temps
très accessible il nous est très
important que le dialogue entre nos pays
soient préservés et que l'on garde la
possibilité d' échange des oeuvres d'art
uniques qui sont conservées dans les
musées russes et bien sûr nous attendons
les expositions françaises en russie à
moscou à saint pétersbourg et dans
d'autres villes
la culture fait c'est un vecteur de
communication de tout un pays est ce que
vous considérez que que l'image de la
russie et
ne correspond pas forcément à votre
réalité ou à la réalité que vous
souhaiteriez qu'elle est lorsque vous
vous promenez dans le monde et notamment
en europe et notamment en france
l'impôt cazin il nous est très important
lors de ces grands événements de
présenter d'une part l'image qu'on a de
nous mêmes et d'autre part vous savez
maintenant à moscou au kremlin il se
déroule une autre exposition importante
elle s'appelle russie france dix siècles
ensemble
il me semble que le titre de
l'exposition qui se déroule dans les
locaux du kremlin à moscou traduit comme
jamais la position de moscou et celle du
ministère de la culture à l'égard de nos
deux pays
deux cents oeuvres uniques et rares
ainsi que les documents les plus rares
et méconnus sont unis par cette
exposition
nous comprenons que les dix siècles de
guerre et de paix était une période de
relation unique entre les dirigeants de
nos deux pays
entre les hommes politiques
et bien sûr la période de dialogue
extraordinaire entre les artistes et les
acteurs de la culture
il est important de préserver cette
tradition
vous parlez de de fructifier d'améliorer
le dialogue notamment au niveau culturel
entre entre la france et la russie le
français autrefois a été une des langues
officielles quasiment de saint
pétersbourg la culture française a été
une des plus diffusée notamment à saint
pétersbourg une fois de plus est ce que
on en est où en est on aujourd'hui de
l'apprentissage du français et de
l'apprentissage entre guillemets de la
culture française dans l'est dans les
écoles dans les universités russes
vous savez toutes les écoles bilingues
franco russe de l'époque de l'union
soviétique des écoles d'une qualité
d'enseignement exceptionnel
continuent leurs activités
et accéder à cet enseignement est une
tâche extrêmement compliqué pour les
familles un entretien spécifique est
nécessaire pour y être admis
car il est très prestigieux d'étudier
dans ce type d'école
il est très prestigieux de parler
français je peux dire que peu de choses
ont changé à ce sujet depuis l'époque
soviétique
ma mère a fait ses études à l'école
soviétique qui portait le nom de romain
rolland à chaque passage à paris jusqu'à
son décès ou qu'elle discute avec les
gens que ce soit dans les restaurants ou
dans les musées on lui demandait d'où
elle venait de quel parti de france et
elle répondait avec fierté je suis né à
moscou j'ai tout simplement fait mes
études à l'école soviétique
alors cette exposition témoigne les
russes la russie a beaucoup aimé la
peinture française
dieu sait si dans au pavillon à la
fondation vuitton il ya un certain
nombre de tableaux que l'on découvre
mais au-delà de ça on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les russes aiment le
cinéma français depardieu il m il m il
aimait beaucoup belmondo on a vu au
moment de la mort de belmondo au delà
des acteurs eaux de la baie au delà de
du cinéma au delà du théâtre aussi
qu'est ce que les russes aiment en
france mais qu'est ce qu'ils aiment chez
les français
quelles questions intéressantes
bien sûr les russes adorent voyager
la pandémie nous a freinés mais voyager
en france est un rêve absolu pour nous
tous
et beaucoup d'étudiants et de jeunes
actifs aspire à se rendre en france
[Musique]
cela est dû au fait que nous étions
élevé dans cette culture
encore une fois je le répète depuis
l'époque soviétique ce dont vous parlez
c'était surtout le cinéma français qu'on
a tout simplement adoré le cinéma
préférée en urss était le cinéma
français après le cinéma soviétique
c'était des expositions permanentes et
bien sûr c'était la mode française la
cuisine française
tout le monde a essayé de la reproduire
et tout cet amour a survécu il me semble
alors que la france faisait son adieu à
belmondo tout notre pays regardé et a
suivi cette émission en direct et sur
tous les réseaux sociaux les jeunes
aussi bien que la génération des aînés
écrivait adieu mon artiste préféré je
les adore c'est la pire journée de ma
vie ils ont publié des photos rares de
cet acteur aucune manipulation politique
n'est capable d'initier un tel mouvement
un tel mouvement de masse venant de tous
les coins de notre pays ne peut être
soulevé que par un élan de coeur
le dialogue culturel rapports culturels
tassé fort vous venez de de le montrer
de l'expliquer les relations au niveau
des artistes du cinéma aussi est-ce que
ça peut permettre d'améliorer les
relations sur le terrain diplomatique
politique parce que c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus compliqué beaucoup plus
difficile
je suis certaine qu'il peut et bien sûr
qu'il le doit et ça a toujours été le
cas vous savez cette année nous avons
remporté six nominations à cannes des
jeunes cinéastes pour lesquels c'était
le sommet de leur réalisation c'était un
grand bonheur il y a eu en tout six
nominations et trois prix
non ils sont rentrés chez eux comme de
véritables héros
c'est avant tout une tradition ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est pour suivre la voie de
tarkovski de concha lossky de mikhalkov
d'une part
et de l'autre par arriver à cannes
monter les marches et grâce au festival
de cannes montrez leur art leur cinéma
au monde entier ça restera à jamais le
rêve absolu de tous les cinéastes russes
oui madame et miss pop pour terminer ou
poursuivre ce que vous venez de nous
expliquer parce que la politique
culturelle est un des fondamentaux de la
relation entre entre les peuples c'est
andré malraux lise la culture du général
de gaulle qui qui le disaient qu'ils le
criait même aux efforts est ce que c'est
ça que vous êtes en train de préparer et
est ce que vous allez faire les mêmes là
même la même conviction ne fait pas de
la même ambition avec les autres pays
européens que la france parce que parce
que nous sommes dans un ensemble
européen ces témoins
bouscasse il est difficile de ne pas
être d'accord avec cette affirmation
c'est vraiment le cas et nous sommes
témoins comme an grâce à de tels projets
à un dialogue et à la communication
permanente ce lien persiste il y à des
périodes différentes dans les relations
entre les pays nous comprenons
parfaitement qu'il devrait toujours y
avoir un dialogue culturel
dans les années les plus difficiles
entre nos deux pays des coproductions
cinématographiques ont eu lieu de
diverses expositions se sont déroulées
malgré tout et bien sûr il est très
important pour nous de garder cela aussi
bien pour le ministère que pour nos
artistes qui ne permettront tout
simplement pas notre existence sans la
collaboration avec leurs collègues
français
pour eux c'est une forme de
communication et de travail continu qui
ne peut pas être arrêté et nous sommes
heureux de les aider de les soutenir de
planifier de nouveaux événements
par exemple l'année prochaine un sommet
des musées prévu entre nos deux pays
les dirigeants des plus grands musées
vos vedettes et leurs collègues russes
se réuniront et discuteront des projets
communs de la façon dont ils vont
évoluer ensemble et des projets à venir
je crois que de tels sommets sont
parfois plus importants que certains
sommets politiques
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je
rappelle que cette exposition à paris de
la collection des frères morozov restent
ouvertes jusqu'au 22 février de l'année
prochaine 2022 après quoi je crois mais
vous me meut le confirmerait que cette
exposition la plupart de ses tableaux ne
pourront continuer de les voir
au à saint-pétersbourg au musée de
l'ermitage est sans doute à moscou
acteur notre exposition du rage 22
février
donc tous ceux qui le souhaitent et qui
auront la possibilité de se rendre à la
fondation louis vuitton pour voir la
collection des frères morozov sont les
bienvenus et ensuite elle retournera
bien sûr un moscou et à saint
pétersbourg
là d'où elle vient
et je crois savoir que ses tableaux une
fois rentrés en russie
ne ressortiront jamais de la russie
pourquoi pourquoi pas
tout d'abord nous envisageons un grand
nombre d'expositions dans notre pays
nous avons le même dialogue avec nos
collègues italiens et des collègues
d'autres pays donc bien sûr ils
resteront en russie pendant un certain
temps
mais je n'exclus pas leur voyage
ultérieur dans d'autres espaces
culturels
ils vont prendre goût au voyage sont des
vecteurs de
solidarité c'est tout à fait possible
mais vous savez nous avons suffisamment
de collection qui n'ont jamais été
présentés en france donc les toiles de
l'exposition des frères morozov peuvent
rester quelques temps à moscou et à
saint pétersbourg
et nos autres chef-d'oeuvre conservé par
les musées russes peuvent être envoyés
pour la troisième exposition de la
fondation louis vuitton nous serons très
heureux pourquoi pas merci mille fois
merci beaucoup ce pas si beau merci
beaucoup de cette opportunité d'échanger
autour de l'exposition à venir merci tu
plais mission est terminée vous pouvez
la retrouver bien sûr en rediffusion sur
la chaîne en replay mais également sur
le site internet de rt france point tv
merci à tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]